june shows coming up june 24th i'm in
des moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media look i want to start this
episode
uh again with gratitude thank you thank
every single one of you for your support
thank you for
all that you do the messages i can't i'm
telling you you're changing my life as
well i mean that all right so if you're
watching on youtube please subscribe it
helps a lot it's a free way to support
the show right and then if you have to
have more honeydew and who doesn't
uh you got the patreon it's called the
honeydew with y'all all right we do an
episode a week all right it's five bucks
a month if you sign up for a year you
get over a month free you're also
getting the honeydew a day early ad free
at no additional cost all right if you
or someone you know has that story that
has to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com uh currently
every thursday we're releasing 10 of our
favorite patreon episodes on the main
youtube so you can get a taste of what
it's like it's one of the 10 episodes i
highlighted with josh wolfe um and there
are
90 some other ones i promise you it is a
wild show and worth every bit of it if
you can afford it all right the night
pants nation tour continues guys thank
you for your support we have sold out a
show or more in every single city i've
been in all right so thank you des
moines i'm headed your way june 24th one
night only omaha june 25th one not only
in brea california i'll be back there
jason ellis will be with me brenton
biddlecombe will be with me and we'll be
there on june 30th all right now you
guys know what we do over here i always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers we're going to be
highlighting the lowlights with a guest
who's first time here on the honeydew
been waiting a long time for this i'm
very excited ladies and gentlemen please
welcome salvato
wow
that's nice i feel that energy man i'm
stoked to have you here um all right
before we get into whatever we're gonna
talk about please plug and promote
everything you'd like all right yeah
sure right now i got a i do two podcasts
one with christa stefano called hey babe
i do another one with joe derosa um
called taste buds where we argue
intensely over food
both of those can be found on the no
press channel on youtube or on spotify
itunes and that kind of thing
uh i'm touring uh my my uh tour dates to
be found on my website
savilecanocomedy.com as well as
all that other stuff merch and and
things like that so let me see i will be
in
uh
rochester on june 10th uh syracuse on
june 11th we got uh i'm joining bert uh
for a festival on june 16th in south
bend indiana with a bunch of other
comics it's gonna be a lot of fun i say
bert as if everyone knows but i'm sure
that dude i know bert kreischer yeah uh
june 17th in milwaukee at the pabst
theater june 18th in minneapolis at the
pantages
and then let's just jump around a little
bit because i just announced a bunch
more uh i'll be in vegas my first ever
in vegas congrats july 15th at the
theater at the virgin hotel uh phoenix
july 16th boulder colorado july 17th and
then portland july 20th seattle july
21st and uh july 22nd in vancouver and
then last thing i'll do because these
got postponed and i want people to know
they're still out there i'm doing
louisville on november 18th in
evansville indiana on november 19th the
home of don mattingly the home of dawn
man yeah go see sal go see him thanks
for listening through all of that of
course
um i just want to say this too before we
even begin uh and this is something
going way way way back i remember
court tv
during the daytime
and then about halfway through the day
or maybe it was the night they would
switch to this true tv
that had you guys on it yeah
this is how many years ago when when you
started how many years ago was it that
court tv was still on during the day uh
i i i think that when we started that it
might have just stopped just stopped
just stopped because i remember when we
started there was three towing shows
i'm not joking yeah there was three
lizard lick miami
three towing three shows and seven
cupcake shows i still can't get a
goddamn show
and there was a pawn show like like what
there was like the original and then
they did them and then there was the
original storage wars and they did so it
was all that kind of television what
year is that this is uh we got to deal
with them i think in 2010.
okay so 12 years yeah yeah and to see
your [ __ ]
flyer on a comedy show and i think we
were the first straight comedy we were
the only non-reality show people still
refer to us as a reality show when we're
not a reality show i mean they think
it's just
they group us in with unscripted into
reality but we're very much we're
unscripted in certain ways but we're
very much scripted we have to think all
this stuff out we write a ton of jokes
we improvise in the moment but we're
very much scripted too but yeah and then
and then i think it kind of like
we can't believe it but it kind of
altered the i guess the the the mo of
the of the network and the whole thing
that you got comedy yeah you were the
anchor i can't even yeah it's crazy and
then to see you we did the vegas
festival a few years back yeah and i was
saying to watch you walk through a
casino and be stopped yeah
every second i was like man this [ __ ]
guy is
hell yeah and then you've just good for
you dude thanks thank you good for you
yeah yeah they play the show enough it's
sickening how much it's everywhere who
cares let them play yeah it's it's
always repeatable so they play the [ __ ]
out of it we end up getting syndicated
and so after all this time it's like you
could turn on a television and
we actually got some statistics and we
were on the air 51 percent of air time
no on all tv a few years ago we were
renegotiating our deal they were like
yeah they're not on on their networks
fifty-one percent fifty-one percent of
time you turn on
of every other show
so i was like that is a little weird but
also like fine i mean it's
that's how that's i think really
if they didn't repeat the show like that
i mean that really helped a lot yeah
yeah
but now you're out in theaters you're
doing everything so
um i asked you to do this you're like i
don't really know what i wanted to talk
about and you know just quickly you
started crying so what
dude i'm not kidding you
guys if this is about that
get ready because i i tell everyone all
the time i'll cry at a pep boys
commercial i'm not even kidding around
just give me one moment in a commercial
i'd hear i actually wonder like you know
what's wrong with me that i can cry that
quickly that easily a song that means a
thing of that like anything i see a
tender moment in the streets yeah crying
something happens something happens
i'm the same way i'm i'm very um this
the saying i heard before was i come in
peace ready for war and i am very much
pet the puppies and hello the kids and
you know and then i'll go over here and
i'll cut your [ __ ] throat out
okay
all right
yeah i don't take [ __ ]
i will
cry i cry a commercial yeah see man i
mean if i hear like if i even hear once
move that bus i just started crying
i remember i don't it was the hall of
fame and it was chris carter he had
gotten accepted oh yeah vikings uh-huh
and he got up and you know he was with
the eagles first and then had his
addiction problems and then came back
and really you know that boy catches
touchdowns
and i guess
i i don't know what his background was
but he kept talking about his like older
brother who was like a dad to him and
who really took care of him and he just
starts bawling he goes i can't remember
his name uh
he's like uh
whatever joe carter
you going to the hall of fame too i
started balling i'm by myself there's no
other car i'm buying myself
[Laughter]
in 1998 i was just a kid oh it was in 98
whatever titanic came in
i just watched that with my daughter my
first like young serious girlfriend we
have broken up for the first time i
think i was like a teenager or something
and i used to love going to the movies i
wanted to be like a filmmaker or a
screenwriter back then so i would go see
everything i remember this is so corny
but i remember going to titanic and i
just was going through a breakup my
first real one and i remember in sitting
at a matinee
watching the titanic alone crosstalk for
like three hours straight
by the end like when she just lets him
go
like i was like
crying
crying
i carried out a movie one time it was so
intense in hindsight i don't know if it
would hold up as that intense but vince
vaughn was in it with joaquin phoenix
and it's about this uh and an ann heish
i don't remember what it was called
right paradise oh man i remember this is
a weird one wasn't it so like uh joaquin
phoenix is in another country backpack
and he's just like hippie peaceful guy
and he had like hash on him and they
threw him in jail and they ended up
i mean look this is a spoiler alert but
this movie's 20 years old
what do you want from me
uh
they they sentence them to death
and uh dude they
they hang him in the movie at the end
and like you don't think that's gonna
happen like that's really how movies
work you know and then vince vaughn is
there they were they were on this trip
together and so when they hang him he's
like you you don't know if it's gonna
happen or not i remember i haven't seen
this movie since the time in the theater
i never saw it again but i just it's
ingrained in my head and
it's like about to happen you realize oh
[ __ ] like they're gonna they're actually
gonna do it and i remember like he had
to just like make eye contact with vince
wong right before it happened and they
wouldn't let him go near and he's
yelling through the jail cell he's like
i'm with you i'm right here i'm with you
and then they [ __ ] hang them and i
was bowling in the theater and then
somebody it was like a matinee there was
like eight other people in there and
somebody laughed and i was like man [ __ ]
you i just like screamed i don't do
laughing at the movie or me but i was
like what kind of soulless person are
you i'm bawling right now
and they're laughing
um
you ever have a moment
where
you're somewhere like this happens to me
i've been before it uh i've told this
story before well tell cause you'll
appreciate it so
it was right before christmas
uh like right ninth 2019 before the
pandemic i go into ralph's i'm at the
cold cut counter and i'm asking the lady
you know i want like a pound of boar's
head ham and some cheese and slice it
thin or whatever that's how you do it
and i hear her with the italian accent i
was like oh you know and she's like i go
i'll be right back i'm gonna go grab a
couple things and she goes wait here
talk to me it's just the two of us right
yeah you're east coast right yeah i'm
from baltimore yeah so and my whole town
my whole family's italian yeah my dad
was the mutt that ruined it but everyone
else my mom's side is all italian devito
my grandmom's all the memo you know so
a slice of [ __ ] thing yeah and um
you know she's like stay here and talk
to me she's like what are you doing for
the holidays and i was like i'm just
actually gonna do this year i'm doing it
different i'm not doing turkey and [ __ ]
i said you know when i grew up as a kid
everywhere i went and i didn't realize
until i got older but when i went to my
grandmother's house if it was easter
there was ham if it was thanksgiving
there was turkey but there was also
lasagna stuffed shells baked rigatoni
you know you had all the options yeah
but then we'd leave her house and go to
her sister's house and it's there and
it's there so i didn't
realize until i literally started dating
girls in high school and i would go to
like their event i'd be like where's the
baked ziti in there what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
what do you mean
it's the christmas eve
where are the seven fishes
[Laughter]
i've never done that
you know when i feel like we're going to
get into some stuff and then the hour's
going to be up like in therapy and then
i'm just going to be like crying like
all right
that's the thing about therapy because i
go you know and it's crazy that you look
you'll be like right-handed and they're
like they're like on top of it you know
they're like
you know you could be in the mail
all right so and they just bring out the
like the date book they're like
and when are you good next week and i'm
like oh all right
let me look try wednesday
like and then i'm out of the room there
like 30 seconds before i open that door
i was in the middle of like something
some [ __ ] you know
so i'm at this counter and the lady's
talking to me and i say you know my
grandmom
um
she would always have the italian
options you know and i'm going to do
that this year but i'm also going to get
crab cakes things like that just make a
a smorgasbord of [ __ ] i like for
thanksgiving this is what i'm going to
be thankful for exactly
so um
[Music]
we keep talking and she starts telling
me about her daughter who's dating
someone now and she's gonna be there for
the holidays and we're going back and
forth and she's the nicest [ __ ] lady
we just straight up bond and then she
gives me the cold cuts and i'm like
thank you so much again what's your name
by the way
and she goes carmella and i go i just
write away agave i go
did you say carmela she goes yeah i go
that's my grandmom's name dude
i [ __ ]
stuck the deli counter bro
it's like 7 30 at night
that's not enough i named my company
after my daughter and my grandmother i
named it stella carmela so it's on the
credit card right so i take out the crop
cry
i got my grandparents all their initials
all four of them tattooed on me right
now every single one of my llc's is
named after my grandparents but my first
two companies were one set of
grandparents and the other set of
grandparents no joke that's great it was
my grandparent my first company is my
grand my mom uh my my mom's parents a
dress that they grew up at and my second
my touring company is literally named
rosenetti after my grandparents hell
yeah yeah that's great and then i'm
telling you the weird thing is
i don't remember ever seeing that woman
before and i looked for her after
actively and i never saw her in there
again
and i was like that is [ __ ] crazy
like i wonder if she was just
transferred from another store one night
to cover a shift you know what i mean
i couldn't get i'm bawling at the deli
counter was she taking it back because
she wasn't like she was like why are you
she was right there with me no because
when i said my grandmother's carmela she
got it i was just like
and i mean also seeing a grown man
crying over ham you know what i mean
like it's probably
all right so especially if they don't
slice it then i get upset right away i'm
like this is what you call thin right
here nah does it go you want to break my
arm i'm like going don't shave it either
don't [ __ ] work for four years you
did yeah growing up do you have a deli
slicer at home like a countertop i don't
have one at home i'm getting one yeah i
still have the mark on my finger right
there where i sliced it on a pepperoni
this lady ordered she got a 12 pack of
bun and she ordered pepperoni
yeah
just looked like i sliced it you know
and i sliced my finger right on i had to
go to the hospital
she was annoying all right well let's
talk about
you uh your your background cuz i want
to know where originally are you from
and what was your
you know home life like are you one of
many are you an only child tell me about
that yeah right so
born and raised in staten island new
york uh my parents got divorced when i
was about four
um my dad
so my my dad and mom was my dad's second
marriage my dad got married very very
young he got married at like 17 damn and
he had a a daughter uh and then
like i guess you know one thing led to
another and though his his then
wife or ex whatever it was she took
their daughter and moved to california
now this is like
in the late 60s early 70s so back then
you it was hard to find people if that
happened it wasn't like now like it's
like you're looking through a phone book
if it wasn't listed so she just took the
daughter yeah they just didn't get along
which is your sister yes
well i wasn't born yet right yeah but so
i didn't know her growing up um so and
then my parents got married
and uh and then i had me and then my
younger sister she's three years younger
and then my parents were only married
for like f they might have been married
a few years before i was born but they i
think by it was time i was four
so then they said five years six years
something like that so your mom has two
kids and your dad has three is that
right my mom has two kids and my dad has
uh four kids before he had two oh wait
so
wait there's more
so when they got divorced my dad got
married uh i guess just a couple years
after that still with my stepmom now and
i have my youngest sister
um who's 36 now you know what i mean but
like from that so i have three sisters
one older who i didn't grow up with and
then the two younger ones that i did you
know you know grow up with and uh and
then i finally met my my sister when
when the internet started to be more
prevalent like we we searched her out
and then i met her when i was like in
sixth grade and then what was that like
it was pretty cool did she know about
you guys she did yeah she did but no one
ever connected us and so she came and
she she she stayed with the summer for
us when she was like 17. and i was like
maybe like 12 whatever i was oh yeah
okay and we hit it off and then she
wanted to come she liked it so much she
wanted to just move back but my as my
dad tells me
he didn't want to do what happened to
him
where she just takes her away from the
like you know what i mean the family and
let her come live here because he wanted
to more than anything but i think then
i think that she hadn't like was upset
with that and then we lost touch again
for for years
um and then my youngest sister years
later just was like this is this
shouldn't be this way so she like
communicated with her we got back in
touch again and then ever since that i
mean this is now
20 plus years we're we're all in each
other's lives and i go there and they
come here and my sister has two kids and
one of them my nephew has
uh three boys now so i have uh his my
nephew has three boys and then you know
her daughter and then my sister uh my
sister's three years younger than me has
three kids damn my youngest sister has
two kids uh three and a half and two and
a half but my so i have all these nieces
and nephews but i'm the only one
you know without any kids here right
yeah
what um
who did you live with when your parents
split was it 50 50 or no i lived with my
mom
and it was but it was kind of like okay
because like we lived in these apart
like these garden apartments i know the
garden department you know yeah i know
so my dad had like three jobs he was
like a sanitation worker for new york
city but he was also the superintendent
of all those apartments okay so
he
because of that had rent free so then we
moved into the building just right next
to his okay so he still had him right
there and he was around the corner so i
would just i would see him but like we
would go every sunday to to be with him
and then when we got a little older we
switched it to every other weekend and
we'd stay with him for the weekend and
then in like 92 my mom or 90 my mom got
remarried in 90. she was remarried for
four years i didn't really like the guy
and so i i moved in with my dad when i
was like 16.
it was great you know just great and
then i lived with him until like i moved
out of the house which was like in my
early 20s or whatever it is a hectic
time of the year you got graduations
weddings spring sports and more we're
all busier than ever right now and with
work friends family a million pressing
social issues it can feel like there's
an expectation to be on 24 7 and
sometimes we forget to take a second for
ourselves so this season
take a second to enjoy an ice cold coors
light because you deserve a beer that's
made to chill
it is my absolute favorite light beer
it's been my favorite light beer since i
was in high school
the mountains on the bottles and cans
even turn blue when your beer is cold
that way you always know when it's time
to chill when you need to hit reset just
open a coors light it's cold lagered
cold filtered and cold packaged it's as
crisp and refreshing as the colorado
rockies perfect for a moment to unwind
when i need to take a second for myself
you know i'm reaching for the beer
that's made to chill get coors light
delivered straight to your door with
drizzly or instacart by going to
coorslight.com
honeydew coors brewing company golden
colorado celebrate responsibly if you're
smoking cannabis there is a way to call
flesh and enjoy chilly smoke with zero
chest or throat burn and the solution is
a freeze pipe freeze pipe makes a unique
line of freezable pipes bubblers bongs
and more and the secret is freezable
glycerin chambers on every piece you pop
one of these glycerin chambers in your
freezer for about an hour and a smoke
passes through the icy chamber it's
instantly chilled for a bigger colder
and smoother hit i've been using mine
non-stop and i love it i'm coughing
barely at all
um i love joints but the paper makes me
cough that's for real freeze pipes
founders were tired of overpaying for
pipes and bongs at local head shops and
with the state-of-the-art glycerin coils
and water filtration freeze pipes pieces
cool smoke by over 300 degrees most
people report they cough way less with
freeze pipe but everyone reports it's
the nicest cannabis smoking experience
they've ever had if you're tired of
burning throats or coughing too much
when you light up visit
thefreezepipe.com and use code honeydew
for 10 off that's the freezepipe.com use
code honeydew for 10 off and say goodbye
to harsh cannabis smoke you don't have
to choose between better hair growth and
your health there's a holistic solution
for men that promotes both healthier
hair and whole body wellness nutrafull
is the number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness and visible scalp
coverage neutral fold goes beyond
genetics to multi-target the root causes
of thinning physician formulated using
natural medical grade ingredients
neutrophils drug free patented
technology provides consistent reliable
results without compromising your sexual
health in a clinical study men showed
progressive improvement in hair growth
and thickness after three and six months
neutrophil is also trusted and
recommended by more than three thousand
top doctors you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support the show by
going to nutrifoal.com
men and entering the promo code honeydew
to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it's only available to us
customers for a limited time plus you're
getting free shipping on every order get
fifteen dollars off at nutrafold.com
men that's spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l
dot com slash men promo code honeydew
now let's get back to the dude and you
still have a good relationship with both
your parents oh the best ever yeah my
dad is my best friend but that was you
know my bed is my best friend you know
like my mom to my mom talk to my mom
every single day have you been able to
tell your mom you weren't crazy about
that dude
oh i told her like
i told her at the wedding
i was like ding ding ding ding i want to
just say a few things
he was a tool man and that ended he
didn't treat her good he was a he wasn't
a good dude
i mean you know you know if he's
watching and maybe he is i mean i hope
you you've come a long way but um that's
not you're so nice
yeah so that was like you know my mom my
mom's great my mom i've never
this is nuts it's gonna sound nuts and
it's not even an overbearing way it's
just a cool
check-in way but i've never had a show
even spots where my mom didn't text me
at the beginning like good luck with
your spots and then after like oh the
next day be like how were the sp how was
your show last night before and after
i'm talking
f 2000 sure whatever whatever we do
before and after spots tour
anything
it's break a leg right before showtime
every night and then that night or the
next morning how are your shows man you
talking about somebody who's supportive
as [ __ ] yeah trying to think how many
times my mom has done it oh zero
that's absolutely my dad doesn't really
do it he's not good with text you know
still what a mom yeah but sometimes it
could be a little too much not that but
like you know she's also like how do i
work the remote and i'm just like i
can't today i can't today yeah you know
the remote you know you've been using it
for a while you know sometimes you're
like my you got to figure that out
so we were talking before the show and
you said that you have crippling anxiety
yeah where do you think it comes from
and and just describe what anxiety is
like for you because i know for everyone
it's different
yeah it's like a mix of anxiety and
depression i guess i don't know where i
really don't know where it comes from so
my
not particularly my mom's parents but my
dad's
mother my grandma rose was a
a worrier by nature worried about
everything wonderful lady she was like
the mayor of our little neighborhood
she'd be like sit down sit outside
people waved at my grandpa my mom
slaughtered my grandma and my dad's side
were the mayors of this of the town um
but she was always worried wherever i
worry and my dad is a warrior and my mom
even though they weren't really warriors
she is too
and i always was like oh god it's so
much worrying but i
i think it's inevitable like i i'm i'm a
warrior and i i compared to them i was
always like look i see what they how
they are and i'm not gonna necessarily
be that way but then you just start
being that way you know
so i worry a lot too and i i guess i get
maybe anxiety from that i what worries
you what do you think about daily like
what's getting at you the number one
thing that i like go to therapy about
the number one thing that gets to me all
the time is death
the thought of death
of my loved ones
predominantly my parents
uh and then you know
you know
people like my
my my girl i'm in a relationship with or
like you know just the day that that
comes or myself like what that moment is
gonna be like how it's gonna happen when
it's gonna happen i'm so tight my
family's tight you know i'm so tight and
i just can't imagine i cannot imagine a
world without them and i just start to
sit there and think about like
it's weird i like you know you can
choose what to focus on but
i have like diagnosed like adhd i know
people say that but i have it like
diagnosed and a little bit of ocd
and it is
like uh i i lived with it for so long
and i didn't understand that like that
wasn't normal thinking about that
thinking oh about everything like
obsessiveness and but death is a big one
and but but just the obsessiveness like
you know
and i i like i'm not able to focus on
anything and i'm not able to complete
tasks and i'm not able to remember
anything it's a really weird thing like
it scares the [ __ ] out of me i'll walk
into a room forget why i walked into it
i'll start a sentence sometimes
especially when i'm overstimulated or i
have a lot on my mind and i won't
remember what i was gonna say or do and
i'll like be talking to my girlfriend
and i'll be like you know and i'll just
be like i forgot so if anyone i i live
and die by this so you say to me
something right there and i gotta
remember it i write it down saying i can
open up my notes there's a hundred notes
every note is a hundred pages they're
broken down to i live my life lists
categories i have priority lists
secondary lists i have i got a tertiary
share i got church i have like all right
this person's name what things i need to
speak to them about this important thing
like everything you can think of and i
have to look at it otherwise i won't
remember and i i i went and i i got
tested and they were like oh you have
like sevilla and they gave me um
what's it called uh time released uh
to be hyper aware
no no not really
whatever it is you know yeah i do know
what you're talking about yeah
it's like speed for adults at speed and
for kids it slows them down yes yeah
yeah and they gave me that
i got it out lateral and i don't really
like i don't really [ __ ] with like uh
i'm afraid of like prescription stuff
and all that stuff
but i said i don't do this kind of stuff
and he said i said i won't do it you
know he goes just do it on days you feel
you need to help in the days you're
overwhelmed oh you can do that
adderall's uh that's what they told me
i waited i waited and then uh i had a
day and it took a while and i i didn't
took the first time and i guess it was a
time release they gave me the wrong dose
and they gave a time release dude i was
up for 48 hours it's a stereotype though
i cleaned the whole house i was sweating
my heart was pounding i knew that it was
happening like i was like this is like
cocaine it must be i never did coke i
was like this must be what it's like my
girl went to bed i was
drenched in sweat walking around house
scrubbing stuff cleaning doing things
and i guess in that respect but then i
was like i'm gonna crash at some point i
didn't crash that night i was like i'm
gonna crash the next afternoon i didn't
crash didn't crash it next night i went
to sleep the following night at like
four in the morning off that one pill
off the one pill and my
i woke her up in the middle of my bit my
heart is beating out of my chest and
that was it i never did that ever again
and i told my doctor recently because
that was like six seven years ago and he
was like man because they gave you the
wrong thing the wrong dose we could work
with this you know
so he was like we're gonna work with i
said i have depression anxiety and i
have this adhd and they both play into
each other because i i can't get
anything done he's like we got to treat
one at a time so he's like which one you
want to treat first because they do play
into each other so we started to treat
the anxiety first so i did go on
medication for that so i went on that
like maybe like uh six eight months ago
maybe whatever it is now
and it has helped it has helped and now
so now that's leveled out and now i'm
gonna try to treat the adhd but
dude death
i just started thinking of i i focus on
such sad [ __ ] i just because you think
about it you've never experienced a
major death in your family so i've had
i've had three of my grandparents pass
okay and i've had my best friend one of
my best friends in the world past so
those were the big ones for me and then
i had some like really crazy stuff like
you know you know although other than
that but uh i just like if you think
about life it's so sad because
when you're on the way out that you know
that old it's like you know you revert
back to a child that'd be taken care of
um
diapers people have to wipe you and if
then you can't get at home care and then
all of a sudden you're and that [ __ ] is
lonely that happened to you know my one
grandpa
died suddenly from an accident he hit
his head and he was on blood thinners
and we didn't know and that was he went
before his time oh and that was super
tragic he internally bled but
when we found them he they got to put
him on like you know life support and
then we had there was nothing no no
coming back
his wife my grandma
was in 85 smoked her whole life was
danced the night away every night then
one day she had a mini stroke she went
to the hospital and then she was there
for a few weeks and it was like in and
out in and out and then she came to and
we're going to get her home and it
happened again and then we lost her but
like right before that happened there
was nothing perfect you know
and then my other grandpa was like one
of my best friends i saw him live out
the life in a nursing home
and
i was a person who would see my
grandparents at minimum once a week i
lived with them growing up for a while
really really close you're so similar
yeah
you know so
i would go visit him and he would
and
i would look at him and just be like
nobody's here right now like we could
only come in shifts when people have
lives and he's laying there bedridden
and i would go see him and another thing
that happens i hate this but like you
lose you know your memory you know you
start getting this dementia you stuck in
all this stuff and i'm seeing it i have
one grandma still alive she's 90 or 93
we're not sure
why
i get one yeah she's 90 or 93 because
because she has a birth uh her birth
certificate says something different
than like photos we found on the back
with dates on them and back then you
know so
and she's
still she's still with it and everything
but she's her short-term memory is gone
so i'll and and it's gotten worse over
the last year significance i'll talk to
her and then she'll forget like
something that i asked her like and i've
seen that happen but it's saddest thing
to me because
the thing that we have to take with us
is our memory
so i look at my grandma i feel so bad
because i love her so much but she
doesn't remember anything like she came
to see me at the
at the beacon theater like a couple
weeks ago that's nice and she won't
really remember that
but at least she was there you know but
but it's so depressing you know and then
i'm like that's where we're all going
that's where i'm going it's like what at
the end what do we have any of you were
supported and loved and live this life
with all these experiences
there's going to be a day that you're
just laying there and
people see you in shifts here and there
and you just sit in there man and then
you start forgetting stuff and my
grandpa we would go see him and then
he'd be like kind of have to remember
who you were and that's crushing because
he's like my bestie you know like to be
like
sometimes he would always remember but
you know and i would
you know he would tell me like i hate
this life this is not a life i just want
to go i just want to go you know
it's so sad here and then when i had to
leave i would just sit there by a side
like i would go at least once a week but
he was in another state
so i would drive this and i would see
him like once a week and i'd just go in
there i'd sit down with him
bring him like his favorite food and
stuff and i would just sit there and
like try to talk to him i remind him of
all the stories he would tell me which
he didn't remember anyways
and that's crushing because my
grandparents were all storytellers and
we would listen for hours they had a
million stories and i would try to get
him to jog his memory tell him his
story's back but that's why i'm glad we
have this yeah yeah i i've always told
my daughter's mother if something ever
happens to me you tell her to listen
every episode of the crab feast and
every episode of the honeydew and she'll
know exactly who her father was i know
and i started to uh when i this affected
me a long time so i started doing these
things where i'd set up tripods and i
would like
to start talking to my grandparents and
i started taking down notes about our
family tree because i want to like go
back and figure out where i came from
and a lot of stuff and so i started
those projects but i didn't but now i'm
like no i'm going to do this thing where
i'm going to either write or film myself
telling all the stories to a camera
so that my kids kids or their kids and
them and then i just you know so all
that stuff gets to me so much and i'm
like i don't want to see my parents go
do that i don't want to go to the
i focus on that [ __ ] and i and i'm like
i cannot imagine a day
you know until i think i'm having i
think it's more of a midlife kind of
thing and i don't think that the
pandemic helped because it it for me
i'm already that all day every day and
that's it was a it amplified it times
10. sure and i'm thinking oh my god like
anything can happen to my parents right
this second and i don't have any kids
yet and i started thinking oh man i
waited way too long because i want my
parents to know my kids you know and and
i'm not gonna have that or i might not
have a lot of that and then i'm like
wait a minute i i'm not gonna have a
long i'm 45 already by the time i have a
kid you know if i had a kid at you know
25 i'd be with this kid yeah my children
20 years already and that is the most
important thing i've always wanted kids
right so now i'm like damn when i'm like
i do the math when you know when i'm
like 70 my kid's going to be you know
it's like i'm not going to be the old
dad so i have a little regret that way
although you know you can't change
anything
but i really really focus on that stuff
man and i just like where do you think
that comes from why what what makes your
brain turn to
death i don't know i had my versus work
you know what i mean a lot of people
freak out about their employment or
their careers or whatever what is that
always worried me too but i never really
had like i was never had money my
parents didn't come from money working
class family my dad had multiple jobs my
mom was at home with us you know we were
on like government assistance here and
there even like this so you know but we
always had a roof over our heads we
always had food we always find they
treated us we always had good
christmases and you know close with our
relatives but i don't know but like i
just was a good saver like something
about work didn't just bother me i get
it i never had trouble started working
when i was 14 years old you know like
but i don't know i just think i have
maybe i i've never really talked about
my parents getting divorced but like
i know that i don't really extrapolate
maybe it's the fact that
i i don't know i just i hate change
do you since i was a kid i have a lot of
trouble with change
well maybe sal something there's
something to the fact that work
um you know these other things you can
do something about death's undefeated
yeah there you go yeah like there's
nothing
that's really actually really on point
because i have no control and that's the
thing i i'm that type of person that has
to have control i want everyone i know
to be taking care of the healthy good
everything and i go i go nuts
and it makes me feel good but that's i
that's who i am and so like you're right
like people have said that to me before
it's like it's like a code you can't
control it did you do that as a kid with
your mom and dad trying to bounce back
and forth making sure they were always
always man like i just always have been
like that so
you know i start focusing on that and i
and i can't i cannot turn my mind off of
it dude
and because i'm gonna have adhd and
stuff i have these things they call it
they call them loops like i'll wake up
one day and i have a song in my head now
sometimes the song is whatever it's any
song but it can get
very very annoying but i'm telling you
like it'll loop in my head through it
through a day or two days or a week the
same thing and i have to think you then
put it on too no i got to think of
something else okay so i can i'll think
of another song so that i could just
switch
songs you know what i mean yeah like you
think about it if someone was playing
all day like yo i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm going
to find the artist and kill them
but i'll do that with thoughts you know
and so once i get into a rut like that i
can't get out of it and i get so sad you
know and i'm just like you know i i
don't i'm such a happy-go-lucky person i
laugh i have a hearty laugh a lot of
people are going to be surprised by
hearing this about you because you are a
hearty laugh or like when i see you when
i see my friends like i laugh hard when
i go see when i when i'm in the back of
the room and my friends on stage i've
heard their jokes a hundred times i
laugh so hard but from a real place
really i just love to laugh i'm a
lesbian it makes me feel great yeah and
and that's how i am i'm like this like
god like that's so you know but then i
got this the exact opposite of that is
like i'm so sad you know a lot so like
so you you mentioned you lost a a best
friend so
how does all this worrying about death
then end up playing into that
it was just something you saw unexpected
yeah well he was sick he he beat cancer
and then he had all sorts of trouble
like ulcerative colitis and he had all
these health issues and then already or
because of
it was post the cancer okay then the
cancer came back and then he did it
again i believe and then you know and
then he he was just in very very bad
health and he's a young kid he passed
away like in his late in his mid mid 30s
you know this was 11 years ago and he
was a year older than me uh he was like
one of my you know biggest supporters
he was able to see the pilot of the
television show all right for him and i
she's the first person i showed it to
and uh he came to every show i've ever
had he laughed the loudest
what's his name
take your time
yeah
uh doug
so it's hard to lose a support system
like that and he's the buddy who despite
all of his uh troubles and health he
never complained at all and he's the guy
that like would text you
every like randomly just won't let you
know you know i love you and
she's very giving like that i see him
he's always thinking of people always
you know did stuff for people so just a
wonderful person and um
tough tough to lose him i had to you
know speak at the funeral and stuff to
wake and everything and
i have this lyrics on my arm that my
song reminds me of him what is it
he said we used to go out
we were young we used to go out and
party and stuff like that we went to all
these phases and there was one visa we
went out we would go to these like clubs
in the city when we were 20 we'd go out
all night and all that stuff and
uh he was he was
loved music he had you know back when
you know when a person with a record
collection yeah the wall in his room
like bigger than this from the top to
the bottom he had about like i'm
knocking like a few thousand cds and he
would make mixtapes everyone all the
time
records and all this stuff with wall of
records and so he loved like djing and
stuff he wasn't a dj per se but this
song by fat boy slim praise you yeah
and it's from this old song by camille
yarborough it says there's a there's a
really slow soulful version of that
and isn't that right
yeah yeah um but he he you know a fat
boy slim i was it was really like he
redid it in a way and it's just the
words these are the words you know that
of the chorus like you know come a long
way together hard times good celebrate
you
and he loved that song and like it would
just make him happy and so i always
thought of it you know and so when he
passed all of us got it
all friends got it and you know and then
yeah so but uh you know it was it was
that was really really that was tough to
deal with because it was i found out it
was like unexpected and i found out via
a text
unfortunately that he was gone yeah oh
no so you didn't even get the no i mean
i was gonna go
like literally i found out like
like
and a group of people went to go see
them and i couldn't
and so i didn't and i regret that but um
but yeah but it was like it was just i
and but i already felt with the death
stuff like before that
you've already been yeah that was just a
wallop so then it hit you like that yeah
yeah
i just started and you know what i and
then i start like i think it's because
i'm saying i think it's a like a midlife
thing because you don't think about this
stuff right you you you start to like
i'm like oh my god i'm the age of my
grandparents when i was like you start
looking at pictures like they were my
but it's like you're young right and
it's you're invincible i don't ever
think of dying when i'm in the back of a
pickup truck in a lawn chair going 50
[ __ ] right right you know i never one
time not worried about [ __ ] now i'm like
i have my grandparents so late knock on
wood even though i lost
before
but i didn't you don't think of it and
then you don't think i don't think i'm
losing my parents but then now they just
passed into this like my dad is 76 my
mom is
72.
and i think the pandemic
like a couple things happen like for the
first time in my life i saw myself start
to age and some of my friends like i see
us starting to age a little bit and i
see for the first time in my life my
parents start to age and i never really
see that and so it's kind of like when i
look at them you just see them becoming
a little bit more you see it you see the
in their
physicality and their demeanor you know
you just see it and you're like oh whoa
whoa like i never even put my mind there
even though i do but like you know now
it's like now you're like you look at it
and you're like it's right there and
you're like
we've moved into another phase you know
what really sucks getting in the zone on
the treadmill or pushing to finish that
last rep and then your earbuds follow
your ears the music stops your pumped up
mood is gone i've been sitting on the
airplane just trying to watch some shows
while i'm flying around to see you guys
and boom they're out and now i'm
reaching back by somebody's bare feet
that's why raycon's new fitness earbuds
provide a maximum secure fit so you'll
never experience that again raycon's
fitness earbuds help you take your
workout to the next level with the power
of premium sound and smart tech that's
why they were featured in esquire
magazine's best gadgets of 2021 they
were voted best earbud of the year i've
been telling you they were developed and
tested to stay in your ear during the
toughest of workouts these earbuds
deliver maximum comfort stability and
the most secure fit on the market plus
they offer unbeatable battery life nine
hours of play time and 52 hours of
battery total nearly double the battery
life of the other brands on the market
raycon customers love them they've given
the product over 37 000 5 star reviews
now is the perfect time to pick up a
pair because right now you can get
raicon's fitness earbuds for 20 off at
buyracon.com
honeydew and to make this deal even
sweeter
my viewers get an extra 15 off with my
code honeydew this is a limited time
offer so get in now before it's gone
that's code honeydew at byraycon.com
honeydew you've probably heard the
housing market is a mess rising mortgage
rates bidding wars and prices are still
at record highs and rising and
first-time home buyers do not stand a
chance by themselves but the good news
there's a podcast that cares about
helping people navigate the entire home
buying process it's called how to buy a
home host david sidone is an industry
expert with years of experience who saw
the opportunity for first-time home
buyers to take advantage of the crazy
market and since then the how to buy a
home podcast has helped listeners close
on houses they thought were impossible
even as things went bonkers in 21 and 20
22. david has made buying their first
home a reality for so many people and
i'm telling you
i know it to be a fact because when i
was on the road at minnesota this couple
came up to me and they're like we just
bought our first house because of you
telling us about the how to buy a home
podcast that's for real and i was like
are you the couple we mentioned in the
ad and they're like nope we're another
one so boom it's happening out there and
david can help you no matter what stage
you're in he can even connect you with
the great realtor in your area so start
your path today with the how to buy home
podcast and make this the last year you
rent listen to the how to buy home
podcast today find how to buy a home on
youtube and wherever you listen to
podcasts now let's get back to the do i
want to say um i know exactly what you
mean because i was at the 50th
anniversary at the comedy store and i
saw a lot of older comedians and i
wouldn't say they're that old but
they're older
trembling and i'm just looking i was
like man is that the alcohol and the
drugs or is that just what this life
right of
what we do and how we eat and every all
this [ __ ] does to us like how long
before we start [ __ ] trembling and
everything else and i see guys like
i mean i'm a big baltimore oriole fan
even still but brooks robinson's
birthday was the other day and i look at
a guy like this old footage of this dude
diving and grabbing everything and now
he can barely
raise his hand and say hello and i'm
like i was never
i was never in that kind of shape in my
20s what am i going to be like in my 70s
i know if i get there no oh yeah forget
it if i get there i know and my parents
are good my dad's in good shape you know
he's he's he had a couple of he had an
open heart but he's young at heart he's
going to the gym his whole life he eats
healthy he doesn't drink a smoke you
know my mom is is is they're still fully
you know all good
but uh i just can't you know like i just
i'm like oh i'm not
i'm not never going to be you're never
going to be prepared for this never and
you just think of your life and it's
weird you don't
you tend not to go that far ahead
and now all i'm doing is thinking ah
because the older i get the faster time
has been going and that's just how it
works i hear my dad saying getting old
sucks this that and the other now
well you really start to think about
what that means you think about you
mentioned being an older dad and if when
you have a kid and that's what they say
if you want to know
how the passing of time if you really
want to understand and have a kid
yeah and then you're just like you're
five yeah you know you're like what the
[ __ ] you're five right yeah
so i just uh you know i just i just and
i i i can i just whenever my mind goes
to it gets so it's so sad right
there's gonna be a half of my life this
hasn't started yet but like
i hope it's as long but it'll be a half
of my life that my parents are gone and
they don't know
what and my end of my story
which is such common sense right but i
never
think about it that way
and then i said oh man i'm gonna have a
kid one day and there's gonna be
50 years of their life or 40 years of
their life that i will not know about
like 40 years of the most important
person
in my life that i won't get to see or
know about and that kind of like broad
broad feeling is what i walk around with
so i you know and it's
common sense stuff but when when i stop
to think about it it's
so sad
you know it is it's like all right you
know that's [ __ ] life dude but life
is [ __ ] sad it's like i gotta force
myself to like think about the positives
because
for me it can be just doom and gloom
sometimes you know and what comics and
like yeah i gotta go on tv and like i
gotta check that [ __ ] we gotta go on
stage and check that [ __ ] you know and
sometimes it's like i'm carrying that
with me underneath you know and it's
like it's i mean everyone does but
that's what shows like this are for
though you finally get to [ __ ] talk
about but it's crazy people don't think
like that i haven't thought of it like
i'm crazy but i'm like you just hit such
and my dad died at 42. i was 16. yeah i
am 49.
33 years of his son's life he has
another
story
[Laughter]
if life goes the way it should go yeah
then you're right we don't know why like
so it's just that's the way it's
supposed to go that's the way it's
supposed to every moment of my life i
know they i i've had them with me
they've supported me they know
everything about me texting you right
before you're getting right right
and then like and then you know and who
knows how but then that's it they're
only going to know up to a certain point
and then that's it and then that
me and my kids and i'm just like dude
how do you not how do you not think
about that
like how do you not think about it you
know like i understand like be in the
moment and meditate and the [ __ ] the
power of now and and you know like
monkey taps oh yeah all this stuff yeah
okay
okay fine but like
i don't know my my i keep going i have
to keep course correcting yeah
and you thought of the night that you
won't get the text for the first time
ever before you're walking on stage
uh does that go like what
i don't want to call them fantasies yeah
but no i go there i think about
i think about when how i always think
about what i want to know if i could
know or not you know i i guess i mean
ahead of time yeah like i get you know
you know that's fantasy like would you
want to know how you're going and how
you learn everything and i guess no
because without that then i could at
least have hope you know anything like
that but like
i i don't know how to
lose
like that kind of love
crazy i think about it all the time well
you don't it gets taken you don't lose
you don't lose it it gets taken yeah man
so i feel like you know i don't know
maybe it's trite what i'm saying but
like i don't i just no yeah
so that's you really struggle with that
huh really that's a daily fight for you
daily yeah
so at any time too and when i think
about it i get emotional like
i'm trying to work on it but i'm a guy
who'll be like you know
walking down the street or talking and i
and i get something
like something that hits me and i'm like
oh [ __ ] and i got a whole i gotta
literally hold hold back do you know
what gets me you know and it's i don't
know if people like i don't know
that happens to people i don't know what
happens to me i do meet and greets and
the one that gets me the most when
people tell me their stories are nice
that gets me but here's the one that
gets me because again my father was my
best friend i lose him i'm 16. here
comes i can't imagine and then a kid
that's like i brought my dad tonight and
i'm like oh guys let's get a picture you
know they're like
i'm like i'm so every time it's like hey
this is my son we came together i'm like
this you guys came to a comedy show
together and like to see me and they're
like yeah
oh [ __ ]
i got a funny story you just remind me
i'm a wrestling fan when i was like it
was like yeah i want to say at this
point it was maybe maybe almost 20 years
ago 15 20 years ago rowdy roddy piper
had a book come out and he's doing a
autograph signing in times square me and
my buddy brian quinn from the show we
went to go wait and we waited on this
line to meet him and he's taking his
time with everybody who waited an hour
to a couple hours whatever and it's
rowdy roddy piper
so he has his son with him
and his son is an adult son's like 20
years old whatever he was and
he's taking the time you see him talking
to people like he's not rushing it he's
looking at them he's really like giving
people attention his son's there he's
sunday and i was like wow something to
see and it was cool that someone's there
so i get up there and i i'm like oh i'm
such a big you know huge fan you know i
said i just you know
i was like i you know me and my dad like
we you know there were a few things that
a few memories i have and a few things
we bonded over when i was a little kid
that i'll always take away and one was
he brought me to wrestlemania 2.
and this is when
roddy piper it was it was they split it
up into three like chicago national
coliseum and there was three main events
and my main event was roddy piper boxing
mr t oh yeah yeah yeah and so my dad we
got these nosebleeds but he said we're
going down and he put me on his
shoulders and we snuck in and we got we
went right up to the front and i had a
polaroid and i'm on his shoulders and
i'm taking polaroids and uh
it's just a memorandum i was telling him
that and i'm like you know so
like it's one of my fondest memories of
my my father is comes from you and he
looks at me and he starts crying roddy
piper he holds his eyes filled with
tears and he starts crying and he gives
me a hug and his son's right there and
he hears it and he looks at his son and
he looks at me and i was like oh my god
and he starts crying so i was like
i got teary eyed and i start crying like
he hugs me and i'm like yeah man you
know it's just really nice and he goes
i'm so sorry when did we lose dad
he's crying and i'm crying i go oh my
dad's in the car
i don't know
my dad's home
my dad's home it was so awkward
and i felt so weird i was almost gonna
be like lassie
you know i almost lied about my dad that
because i was like how do i tell him
that like
something was we missed it was a
miscommunication
and we were crying you meant to tell
them like oh it's fine and we still had
the tears going down the face and
everything it was such a funny moment i
should talk about that on
[Laughter]
too
stage
all right so here's what i want to ask
you because i know people want to know i
you said you'd do therapy medication
like yeah
but what do you
what brings you joy then like where all
right let me ask you this this way
for me um whenever
i set foot on stage i don't care how
long the set is 10 15 an hour
i don't you're somewhere else everywhere
every time
every [ __ ] time like when i get off
stage i'm like i can't believe i didn't
think about splitting that with my
daughter's mom tonight what the [ __ ] so
yeah well that's the exercise we do
right because it comes across like to be
in the moment every night we have to
stand up it's true but you can't always
do stand-up to make yourself feel better
so what else do you do yeah i mean not
just family and friends yeah i know that
sounds like a lame thing but like it's
everything you hang out with them or
cook out or what are we talking about
for years i had standing reservations
where my nieces were coming to my house
once a week for a sleepover oh hell yeah
i'm not in tune with it like i helped
my my
my nieces and nephews are like my
children i'm that close like i know a
lot a lot of times that unfortunately
like i've realized that not every
uncle nice nephew situation is like that
but they're like my kids i'm the
godfather to every one of them i like
non-god children that's great
you know it's and yeah i'm just so so
being with my family um
and then just like you know just my
friends you know like when i'm with
buddies and stuff it lifts my like
that's one thing my my girl tells me all
the time like when i'm down she's like
call you know go into the city you know
go see your friends like you know go go
juice don't do a set go hang with a lot
of my friends are comics you know like
obviously but it's just like you know
it's it's just something that like on
being on stage just gets my mind away
from it you know and uh you know so just
just that kind of thing i mean i i
started to like i i you know i'm gonna
try i keep saying this my whole life but
i'm not a guy i'm not a gym guy i'm not
an exercise guy per se as you can
clearly see
but i i i did i did uh i for a few
projects in here i i would go to the gym
like you know for six months and i had
like a trainer and i i felt that natural
high that you feel so uh that was really
helpful
not just walking with some a walk dude
taking out you're right just some
earbuds in and just don't listen to
podcasts no get away from it on foot
uh a walk music that makes you feel good
yes oh you know you know what the
absolute number one thing is that
it's like a natural remedy for my entire
like is swimming it's just being in a
bot and being in water and i i i pisces
i'm not i'm a scorpio but like but in my
entire life my entire life i i didn't
have a pool growing up but my favorite
thing to do is to go in a pool like
whenever i get a chance to go in a pool
i don't come out and i'm not even making
a joke like it's my whole my friends and
family know this like if i have a pool
if i'm in a pool situation i will go in
the pool for eight hours
and i will come out i won't come out
everyone gets out parties whatever i
stay in the pool alone and i i was was
until recently that i was i was talking
to my girlfriend i was like
you know what like i think i know what
it is like it's something so calming
about the being in the body of water it
slows everything down for me and it's
like that thing like when we're on stage
it's like just in the moment it just it
slows my
embrace mind you you know i wonder if
it's not going back to all the way being
in the [ __ ] womb and [ __ ] you know
what i mean someone told me that
recently i wanted someone was like dude
that is where you came from and that's
what's the most calming thing they just
said that but it is it's like my mind's
going a mile a minute at all times but
are you creative in the water do you
have good ideas yes it's like you know
what's like meditating
i think my ideas come in the pool in the
shower and maybe like
laying down to go to sleep dude driving
in the car i don't listen to the radio
saying i let my mind go
i want to say i'm definitely creative in
water showers um driving but but
laying down to go to sleep but i mean it
is and this is the torture of it and
that's why i live by this go to sleep is
bad though too right before as i'm
falling as i'm drifting into sleep all
of a sudden it's like ding ding ding
ding ding ding oh my god damn it but
they're good oh so now
mine's either way with the sleep so a
lot of times i'll lay down i think you
know what it is when i go to lay down i
know i'm like all right i'm about to go
to bed don't think of anything
don't think of anything but now my brain
is trained to lay down and go okay don't
think of anything and so when you say
don't think of anything you immediately
think of all the things you don't want
to think about sure and so i'm trained
when my head hits the pillow to be like
i'm forcing the bad thoughts out and i
don't always win so then sometimes i'll
be laying there just thinking about bad
stuff when i'm trying to go to sleep but
like when i am distracted i'm trying to
go in the middle of night i'll wake up
with material and write it down you're
like that's how your brain just opens up
you know what i mean so i think it's
like a form of meditation for me so
that's like like swimming
riding a bike things like that or
one form of really good therapy that i i
did like last year
was i was having a real tough time with
the pandemic and everything and i hadn't
been i hadn't listened like music really
loud and i live in an apartment building
so i don't really like can't blast it i
got in my car i lowered all the windows
i got on the highway and i turned the
thing up to like as high as it can go
and i drove for like two hours and i
just screamed the music
and i was literally like literally
singing
you know i was thinking of certain
things i just want to get those feelings
out and i was putting on these like
songs because certain songs trigger like
and and if they they're the ones that
get into the loop that's bad news
because they bring me right back to a
moment if i can't get that song on my
head i can't get the momentum you walk
outside right now and a car rides by
what's the song that would get you
there's so many dude there's so so many
oh god uh i mean there's so many and
some are obvious because they're then by
nature they're sad and some aren't but
they're just they they were making me
bring to that place but like if i
listened like yesterday by ray and ray
charles version of yesterday or uh
oh my god like yeah i mean i just it's
just this it sounds like i don't have
there's so many though um
let me ask you this you want to be a dad
so let's be positive when you're a dad
are there thoughts right now that you
want to
help how you can help your kid
not be like this are you scared you're
going to pass the worry gene i hope not
on to your kids i'm so excited
that's the job of my life right the
legacy i'm i'm so excited to
to have a kid one day and then just
be able to
make them a good human being you know
like i'm gonna try and shield them from
that stuff for sure you know but like i
just i'm really excited to
you know that's gonna be the
relationship that's like you know i had
a conversation with my daughter just
last night actually and we were laying
in bed and um sometimes she's scared to
sleep in her own bed you know and i was
like well you can sleep with me you know
and she's like i want to be a big girl i
want to be like the kids in my class i'm
like listen don't i go not everybody in
your class can swim you can swim you
know what i mean i go don't compare
yourself to other people and being
different is good trust me i said i
can't sit there and worry about the same
thing you're worrying about right now
and i want to tell you it's all [ __ ]
be you there's only one you everybody
else has taken and be the best one of
you you can be period that's all you got
to be yeah you know that's great sounds
like you had good parents though
yeah i mean they weren't always that
directly expressive i don't think
anybody of our we're
we are a different generation of men
than our dads
our dads [ __ ] without condoms didn't
give a [ __ ] we're the age generation bro
you know
[Laughter]
we were like we were scared of sex they
weren't scared of sex right they're
doing everybody
uh yeah they don't go to therapy they
didn't like communicate like that the
love was there it was like there you
know the larger top line lessons were
there i think we're the first generation
of of fathers to actually say i love you
go to therapy speaking of which have you
ever tried pmdr very much love you yeah
i do do it i did it and it actually i
had a friend recommend it to me because
i had some trauma to deal with and i was
like look i go to regular therapy but
this is they were like this is different
i'm telling you i turned a lot of people
on to it and i said i'm gonna i looked
it up i found somebody i went it
worked and it blew me away then it
worked it worked this fast i couldn't
tell it worked relatively fast and i
turned other people onto and they worked
relatively fast for them and some people
like ah i'm like look you got to go to
therapy it's mental exercise it's the
gym you got it everybody's worried about
abs
nobody wants to work this [ __ ] out as
important as the stigma is ridiculous
with it like it's not even about that
it's like if you you have to process
it's like just making an appointment for
processing that's all it is whether
something's bothering you directly or
not you have to take a beat to to just
get out what's in your brain out loud
it's you have to hear it because you
could think it but when you're thinking
it it's not as
pointed you have to just say it and you
release it you know whether it's why
stand up is so beautiful speaking that
out yeah and then you just so i was
telling you before um
i i i mean as far as anxiety goes i
would have what i think anybody would
have is basic anxiety and you know i was
good and then i have a daughter and she
almost gets hit by a car and i'm telling
you
that it was like my anxiety i was saying
was laying in a hammock just chilling
and then it was like i'm up you know and
man i got scared the death of flying
yeah we have to fly i got i used to feel
like a [ __ ] rock star taking off that
[ __ ]
my biggest fear is right right but
number two like the first way my biggest
way is
i don't i don't even like to say it out
loud and i know that's one
death and control i say it all the time
it's not like i can go up and go guys
get the [ __ ] out of here let me fly it
as [ __ ] that's what it is we can't i
talked about this two nights ago
yeah yeah and i said they were like oh
you know they did a friend of mine was
like you know but it's more dangerous in
the i said don't even drive and i said
don't eat right
i'm not talking about i said that yeah i
said but the the mortality rate is a
[ __ ] hundred percent i've been in ten
more
hundred percent and i didn't like flying
i didn't like flying in my whole life
and i never flew at my first plane ride
i was 18. and then it was like every two
years a vacation or something like that
and every time i would be like you know
please everybody and now i'm flying uh
200 times a year and i can sleep on a
plane now i still work i could sleep but
like there's always one point in every
plane ride like i flew here i'm flying
tomorrow london there's always one where
i it's just even if it's for like two
minutes i go
this is nuts this is nuts what am i
doing just even if it's two minutes and
it's everyone and i just like
oh my god and then on the plane you
start your mind starts going oh and you
start picturing it and well my text who
am i what am i who am i how am i those
wheels don't sound right going up what
am i saying what am i doing how am i am
i going to get in touch with anybody
like like i like
for me that is like the worst possible
way the worst possible way because you
don't think about it you know go in the
hole
being reported a plane crash it ruins my
[ __ ] weak because i'm thinking those
people that is the most
insane torture i'd rather fall off a
goddamn cliff i'd rather do anything
than hear all those i think about what
those people all had to
deal with together it is the it gives me
it rips me i dude i it takes me to a
knee to think about people that died and
playing i didn't even tell kirsten this
but i i just had this dream where my
stepson kirsten and tom sagora's tour
manager were on a plane together with a
pilot and i'm watching the plane take
off and then i'm watching it crash but
it's not nose diving this dude's doing
everything he can errands fighting and
then boom it slaps down on the ground
yeah and i'm freaking out because i'm
watching my stepson kirsten and tom's
tour manager and whoever this poor pilot
is the man or woman poor pilot
and um tom's manager calls me and goes i
have bad news and i'm like well you're
not dead
right and now i'm hoping like hell and
this is [ __ ] up yeah that the person
who is
is the poor pilot because i don't want
okay and then i woke up thinking like i
[ __ ] rooted
for somebody
that's nuts
but uh he's got to go he has to go bro
sorry
i start doing that i'm like well sully
landed in the water so that's on there
and then
if we can get to like a patch of grass
something like that i stopped playing a
lot but then i'll be scared
but then and then you see like you still
see like like you know the people going
down the slide
i can still i can still you know and
then i'm like how like how when do you
know that it's going to be okay and then
i'm like then i saw this video one time
dude of a plane and it the plane it it
caught air in a way that i've never seen
and it went like this and it went up and
it just went like that and it was it was
like coming to the ground and it went up
and like i've never seen a plane and
they just a commercial
flight it went up and it just like
twisted and just fell back down and i
was like it was the most
horrifying thing
i've ever seen and i just i can't i
can't get over the flying and i s and i
and i'm afraid so when i start thinking
about it i'm playing like don't what are
you doing because you're putting it into
the universe like there's that [ __ ] like
it could happen good
good if it could happen good like the
avenger i'll put it out to the world the
[ __ ] secret it could happen bad maybe
and i'm like don't bring this [ __ ]
energy into this i look at them like
this little baby no god's not going to
let this little baby die on this planet
how do you feel about how do you fly
when you have a kid
how do you fly i'm thinking
like that's the end everything will be
by tire everything will be i will drive
i'm never going to see
my child will never see it out of the
continent
you're going to see no north and south
america and that's going to be it
because that's
my dad when i was little my dad never
went anywhere without a weapon
what kind of weapon he had everything he
did he he would have a bat and every on
every seat there was a bat and he had
like everything from a bat to a pipe to
like you know in like the stadium to
give out the mini bats yeah so there's
bats everywhere
there's bats in all the cars and then he
would always carry brass knuckles in his
back pocket or a knife
and then you know like so and and i'd
see it as you know my mom my dad just
like it wasn't the thing it just was
like god forbid anything happens i want
to be able to protect the family and i i
never thought anything of it and like
now like if we go somewhere and i'll
take my parents they're a little older
now like or like you know a niece or a
nephew or even my if my girlfriend's
going to like the the crime in new york
has been so crazy and this is all this
subway [ __ ] happening yeah you know the
media will [ __ ] you up the media gets in
your head sometimes it's worse than it
isn't but now i'm just like i went and
got them all pepper spray and i'm just
like because if i'm not there
you know if i'm not there like i will
never be able to live myself like you
know what i mean so i i'm starting now
i'm like i'll check in you know like my
mom my mom goes to the you know whatever
my girl my girls i'm like hey checking
in checking in like how's everything
like just taking uber just take an uber
and say you know but i'm like that
already now so forget about it when i
have like so i am i am them i'm i am
becoming them you know what i mean all
right so
we're going to wrap this up here i want
to calm you down
but so i'm saying like is this people
are going to enjoy this
this is a great episode you think you're
the way to hear the anxiety so it makes
people feel better yeah yeah because we
all have this like
people see you and they they're like
look at this successful dude who is
doing and look what's behind that man
for sure yeah still getting up and
traveling and doing your shows and you
know what i'm saying you're still
persevering you're still pushing through
i hope that helps somebody but i think
these people are going to watch it and
be like what the [ __ ] is this
people who watch the show i don't want
to cry about potentially
i don't know but i'm like i don't i hope
this is entertainment i don't know what
it
is
you do good wonderful i get it but i
just feel like man i almost also feel
like i didn't have anything that
specific
like i just was like god generally i'm
just a sad fellow and it's an hour of
that you'll be playing
juicy you talked about that the fear of
death is probably the number one fear of
i would say most human beings yeah it's
the thing we none of us can avoid it
doesn't matter how [ __ ] like i look at
arnold schwarzenegger now i watched a
video of him the other day pose and i
was like jesus christ like if you go
back and look at arnold schwarzenegger
from the 70s when he's posing i mean the
dude
i mean good lord yeah and now it happens
everybody father time and death are
undefeated terrible okay so everything
we've talked about now i'll leave you
with that i think about when my moment
is tell me who will be there all right
how's it gonna happen you do yeah i
think about who who's no when when i'm
dying
how is it happening who's standing by my
side
will i have my lips about me
like who's who's there what am i saying
what's my parting words then i think
about my funeral all the time you do all
the time who's who's there who's saying
what and i and then another thing is
who's saying i
and i think about oh my god like the
girl i'm with now i'm going to be with
forever like we're best friends and
everything right and i think about and
i'm a little older than her you know not
a lot but a little and i'm just like i
hope i go first
i hope you know but then i'm like oh my
god then like she has to deal with the
loss of me and then i feel bad that she
has to deal i'm gone and she's got to
deal with that too so there's no it's
there's no win on that there's no wind
and that ain't changing no so what am i
gonna do i gotta think about that ever i
think about it every moment of the day
this can't be entertaining to people
i don't even know i will tell you one
thing i'm cancelling this week's therapy
session i'm not gonna lose 275 you just
saved me 275.
i like when i go back in the next week
what do you want to talk about is it
okay if we still talk about the death
i know we've been talking about for 64
weeks but [ __ ] all right
after everything we've talked about so
go see me
hold on
i want a tour i'm a blue i'm a hoot i'll
be in all your cities
i'm crazy
what advice would you give to your 16
year old self knowing everything we've
just talked about what do you go back
and say to 16 year old sal yeah i say
and this is harder to do than not but i
say cut
all the [ __ ] out do what makes you
happy
immediately if there's something you
like to do at 16 it doesn't matter
you're at 18 you could be drafted you're
an adult you could have a [ __ ] family
18 you have the world by the balls you
know and i i you hear that and i heard
it but you don't necessarily put it into
practice you always think there's time
and there kind of is until there isn't
and when there isn't anymore there
[ __ ] isn't and i like started comedy
i started comedy like young i did like
sketch comedy improv i would do write
and stuff and i did a little bit of
stand up out of college a little and
then i didn't and then i had an office
job and then i bought my i had a
business and then i didn't and then i
got the show because i was plugging away
still writing and still
pitching shows
and then finally when i was on the air
my my schedule was so busy and i was
like the only thing i've ever wanted to
do ever since i'm a child is be a
stand-up comedian
i have no time but if i don't dedicate
every single ounce of time that i have
to it right now right now in spite of
all my work then i won't be that and i'm
not going to not be that because all i
ever wanted to be and so i every free
waking moment i've had in the last like
10 years i've done stand-up and i can't
believe
that my job is a professional stand-up
comedian now like that was all i ever
wanted and it happened and i i cannot
believe my life that that is my job i
was like that's all i want and i do it
right now i'm living in front of you
right now i'm saying it out loud and i
blow my own mind that i'm that i did
that and the only regret i have if you
want to call regret because i'm so
thankful that i did it and i'm here now
but i would have started that [ __ ] at
16. i would have started it
younger
i wish i'd been doing comedy for 20 30
years already uh because it's what makes
me happy and like
you know find a way to make money doing
what makes you happy again you hear it
all the time then you'll never work a
day in your life i bust my ass i work
but it's still going to work it means
you love what you're doing it means
something to me don't just go don't go
punch a clock
and not everybody has that liberty but
but but figure it out you know like if
you got to do this thing to to pay the
bills
just try to put yourself on a path to
get to something that that you do that
makes you just feel good you know and
don't waste don't waste any time any
time at all that's great advice yeah i
mean ever it's it's probably hack advice
it's not hacking but it's for hack for a
reason i suppose yeah well now let them
know where you're gonna be and
plug and promote everything you want
again
i have never plugged comedy dates into
just an hour
guys i promise you this is one side
there's only one other side which is a
decide you'll buy a ticket for
at several cannon it's it's so funny to
me to plug socials
volcano on all socials my website is
comedy
dot com
it should it shouldn't i don't should
say several kind of comedy um
this is where i'm on tour right now i
got like 20 30 cities and i'm adding
another another 20 actually by the end
of the year but just i want so in june
i'm in rochester syracuse south bend
indiana milwaukee minnesota hampton
beach and foxwoods and uh
in july i'll be in vegas phoenix boulder
colorado portland seattle vancouver
louisville and evansville and i'm
announcing like another 20 cities real
soon for the end of the year so uh
they're all happening in june and july
and savilecanoncomedy.com and then my my
podcast which is hey babe which is just
anything kind of goes and taste buds
where i argue vehemently with uh my
friend about
everything bagel versus cinnamon raisin
bacon i love it they're both great
brother thank you for real
thank you for coming on dude i have not
done anything like this i love hearing
and it it is it was really really cool
to do i appreciate you thank you for
your time yeah first podcast i think
i've ever recorded on on a sunday i'm
sorry about that don't i just i saw the
window and i just wanted to see you i
can't thank you enough for doing that so
thank you for making it work for us um
and as always ryan sickler.com
ryan stickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
thank you guys come see me on twitter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you